there's kitsch there's camp and then
there's whatever is happening here even
if you're someone who thinks the 1978
Star Wars Holiday Special is
delightfully bonkers you gotta admit
that there are a few aspects that are
rather nightmarish agreed before the
opening credits fans are treated to a
brief scene in which Han Solo promises
to get Chewbacca back home in time for
life day I know it's an important day
after we're dazzled by the star-studded
main title sequence we get to meet
Chuy's whole family and that's when the
dread sets in sure will keys are
theoretically lovable but they're just
really grating here
suddenly there's a huge roomful of
roaring wookies each with a different
vocal pitch and continually moaning for
several minutes straight
is this not super annoying to you the
craziest part their conversations aren't
translated for the audience there are no
subtitles whatsoever it's a welcome
relief when Chuy's rambunctious son
lumpy settles down to watch some
hologram acrobats do their thing but
even after this bizarre spectacle you
find yourself wondering what on earth am
i watching what are they going on about
why are the dancers wearing sparkle
bikinis it's very unsettling stuff on
the best of days it's also really
aggravating throughout the special it's
insanely obvious that the young Star
Wars stars aren't too thrilled to be
appearing in the special Harrison Ford
sounds particularly bored meanwhile Mark
Hamill caked in what appears to be
several pounds of TV makeup evidently
has no idea where he is or what he's
supposed to be doing at least he looks
like he might actually be receiving
transmissions from space what's up
it's Chewbacca and Carrie Fisher an
actress who never shied away from
discussing her prolific drug use during
this phase of her career is clearly well
let's just say she's coping with the
production as best she can
mama it's so good to see you happy life
day Harvey Korman was a comedy treasure
he was a staple of the 60s and 70s pop
culture landscape thanks in no small
part to his brilliant work on The Carol
Burnett Show and in classic Mel Brooks
films like Blazing Saddles his
persnickety screen persona and
impeccable comedic timing made for so
many unforgettable moments unfortunately
none of these moments can be found
anywhere in the Star Wars Holiday
Special
in fact Corman pops up not once not
twice but on three different occasions
and playing three different characters
all of which we'll get to in a hot
minute let's start with the first one
Gore Monda is a television chef and
Chewy's wife mala clearly loves her
cooking show she watches Gore Monda
intently as she prepares the family's
life day dinner of course if your family
has a hearty appetite
I would suggest then that old popular
holiday favorite the bantha rump Gore
Monda is evidently the science-fiction
equivalent of Julia Child
it's a premise that's not without
comedic potential but there's just
something about the frenzied manic
energy that we find deeply unnerving
whipster sorry Gore Monda you and your
four spider-like arms seem to mean well
but you're just a bit much for our
delicate sensibilities no disrespect to
the late Diahann Carroll but exactly how
did this cameo come about perhaps she
thought a star we're special sounded
like a plum gig and she certainly did
the best she could with what she was
given it's just that what she was given
well there's really no way to put it
delicately as you can see and you can
never unsee she depicts the holographic
object of unbridled Wookiee lust hmm is
it getting hot in here Chuy's father
nickname of itchy is enjoying what's
called a mind evaporator this handy
gadget is perhaps responsible for the
Star Wars Holiday Special most on
comfortable moment the bookies family
friend Shawn played by honeymooner star
Art Carney of all people gives it a very
special life Day gift I know how to
explain it say it takes a while for her
to come into focus but suddenly there
she is
the legendary Diane Carol playing some
sort of intergalactic disco nymph much
to the delight of the dirty old Wookiee
I can feel my creation I'm getting your
message
yeah we're getting all the messages
after her coyly seductive introduction
she launches into a performance of the
song this minute it's a perfectly lovely
tune if perhaps very very very very long
and itchy makes the whole thing feel
well
Iggy the way he grunts and the way those
rancid gums flap excitedly it's all a
bit much we can have a good time and in
case you think any of this is accidental
we should mention that the shooting
script specifically indicates that Shawn
presents his gift as if he is giving
itchy the most x-rated piece of
literature in the galaxy
much like Gore Monda the second
character played by Harvey Korman is
also part of an instructional video
drone Boyd is a not so plucky robot who
appears on screen to teach a certain
lumpy high lumpy how to assemble a mini
transmitter so is drone Boyd seen better
or worse than gourmand --is well it's
different very very different the joke
in the sequence if you want to be
generous and call it a joke is that
drone Boyd has a tendency to break down
slurring his speech and occasionally
unable to move
sometimes he talks very slowly or stops
to adjust various robot parts that's it
that's the whole thing and it goes on
for several minutes the worst part drone
Boyd's appearance occurs about
two-thirds of the way through the
special and by that point you're already
starting to get concerned that this
thing is never going to end and then
suddenly you're asked to deal with this
kind of material I just swept slowly or
methodically because this is a job for
being in one of the specials many
awkward scenes we find ourselves at the
moss Eisley cantina the place where Luke
Skywalker and obi-wan Kenobi met han
Solo and Chewbacca for the first time
and this is where we eventually made
krelman the third and final harvey
korman character before you can say
McClung key he's already making your
skin crawl Crowl minh is chatting up the
unflappable bartender ack mina played by
the inimitable Bea Arthur and what is
clearly an ongoing one-sided flirtation
it's played like an old-fashioned comedy
routine with two charming performers and
the special sharpest writing a Kadena's
prickly dialogue is genuinely funny
especially with the laser blast
precision of Bea Arthur's delivery
unfortunately none of that can save the
scene from the icky feeling of watching
a nice guy oof used to take a hint
excuse me I have a customer waiting I'll
be right back
come back soon I'll be waiting
look at poor Ocarina bound by
professional courtesy to put up with him
if perhaps none to politely it's all
just way too real I just came in here
for a drink there is also a bit of a
physical factor in the way krelman pours
a drink into a hole in the top of his
head is that a second mouth up there
that's just always open weird dude the
good times at the cantina come to an
abrupt end following a major buzzkill of
an announcement oh no not on life day
due to increased activity among
subversive forces we are placing a
curfew on the entire TV system affected
immediately that means a kameena has to
occur all her loyal patrons out possibly
forever getting the alien revelers to
leave proves to be a challenge and so
she bursts into a rousing number called
goodnight but not goodbye it's a song
that would get just about anyone out the
door in a jiffy the whole thing is of
course deeply silly but it also turns
out to be surprisingly heartfelt be
Arthur as always gives it her all
strident leap leading to a room full of
rubber headed monster masks is it just
us or does the whole scene end up rather
affecting in the end really it all feels
a bit like Casablanca but with a hammer
head and what exactly is the
relationship between a kameena and this
humanoid rat they're awfully tender with
one another anyone thoughts hello Star
Wars has always seemed to rip off some
real world conflicts
fortunately the films are so fast-paced
fantastical and full of space Wizards
with laser swords you never get a chance
to start dwelling on our real issues
here on earth but the stakes get a
little too real in the Star Wars Holiday
Special especially since it's presumably
geared towards undiscerning children
there's the aforementioned scene in
which authorities clamp down on
so-called subversive activity and then
there's this scene in which a
stormtrooper tears apart a young wook
E's bedroom in search of hidden rebels
happy holidays
in fact the Empire has never felt more
like a Nazi regime than they do here the
special B is a lot of attention to the
domestic lives of civilians you see them
preparing for a joyous holiday
celebration but the festivities occur
beneath the looming shadow of
encroaching fascism its bizarrely
heavy-handed stuff for a holiday special
now as the Star Wars Holiday Special
approaches its climax
Chewie arrives home with an intensely
bored looking Han Solo who basically
manages to trip a stormtrooper to that
stormtroopers death like what just
happened here at last reunited with his
desperately annoying family Chewbacca
begins preparations for life day
apparently this highly anticipated event
involves everyone grabbing whatever orbs
happen to be lying around and then
marching slowly and determinately in
their red cloaks towards a large open
space then they just sort of stand there
finally Princess Leia bursts into song a
life de carril titled a day to celebrate
and it just so happens to be set to the
tune of the main Star Wars theme oh the
pageantry this all begs the question
what on earth is life day in the intro
to her song Leah mentions this is the
promise of The Tree of Life hmm first we
ever heard anything about this tree of
life presumably this is a huge trunk in
the background right is this tree trunk
part of the Tree of Life we may never
know
then there's a druggy montage of random
star war scenes as everyone stands
around presumably meditating on just how
rad Star Wars is maybe that's the true
meaning of life day star wars is red the
winter of 1978 was only a few months
removed from the record blasting box
office run of Star Wars many theaters
kept the movie playing for well over a
year past it's may 1977 debut with the
Empire Strikes Back still a year and a
half away the prospect of a Star Wars
Holiday Special was obviously a big deal
just imagine the thrill of hearing an
announcer finally rattle off the names
of all your favorite Star Wars
characters and then this happened r2d2
has
r2d2 that one's a bit of a
head-scratcher isn't it as true
adherents of the force no r2d2 was
originally performed by the late Kenny
Baker who controlled the droid in both
the original and prequel trilogy x' and
usually from inside the costume there
are conflicting reports as to whether
Baker was actually involved in the
holiday special
sometimes he's credited with working on
the 1978 spectacle but it's worth noting
that filmmaker Mick Garris lists
remote-controlling r2d2 for the holiday
special as one of his earliest gigs
regardless claiming artoo simply played
himself as a bit insulting to the
performers involved and it suggests the
Droid somehow went sentient for this
cheesy variety show of course there's
also the distinct possibility that no
one wanted to take credit for Archie's
performance here the Star Wars franchise
is of course a monster success which
makes the Star Wars Holiday Special
very special indeed and though the films
all have a timeless quality about them
the holiday special is very much a
product of the 70s in fact it looks like
your screen has been lightly smeared in
Vaseline but where else can you find
r2d2 existing alongside Jefferson
Starship playing themselves and also
playing one certifiable clunker of a
song the Star Wars Holiday Special is
unique surprising woefully misguided and
an absolute joy to watch and yes it's
disturbing unless juggling up to drunken
space rats is your idea of a good time
then again who are we to judge love is
love
I'll tell you the secret check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]